UNDER ASSAULT.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
"ANGLE."
THE HISTORICAL PURGE THAT WE ARE
WITNESSING ALL OVER THE COUNTRY
IS PART OF A LARGER AGENDA.
TO DESTROY WHAT IT MEANS TO BE
AMERICAN.
AND IT'S GETTING MORE AUDACIOUS
BY THE DAY.
IN ST. LOUIS PARK, MINNESOTA,
THE GENIUSES ON THE CITY COUNCIL
THERE RECENTLY DECIDED TO BAN
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE FROM
TOWN MEETINGS.
THEIR REASON?
TO CREATE A MORE WELCOMING
ENVIRONMENT TO A DIVERSE
COMMUNITY.
OH, WELCOMING TO EVERYBODY BUT
AMERICANS WHO ACTUALLY LOVE THE
PLEDGE.
RESIDENTS WERE RIGHTLY OUTRAGED
BY THIS INSANITY.
A LOCAL PATRIOTS IT OUT AND THEY
STOOD UP TO THE CITY COUNCIL.
>> TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS, ONE NATION UNDER
GOD'S -- USA!
USA!
>> Laura: THEN IN
SAN FRANCISCO, TAXPAYERS ARE
GOING TO SHELL OUT $600,000 TO
PAINT OVER A GEORGE WASHINGTON
MURAL THAT OFFENDED A FEW
SNOWFLAKES OVER THERE.
LET ME GET THIS STRAIGHT, PEOPLE
BEING IN THE FOUNTAIN STEPPING
ON DIRTY NEEDLES, THAT IS NOT
OFFENSIVE?
BUT THE FIRST FOUNDING FATHER
IS?
PERFECT.
WHY WOULD EVERYONE AFTER HEARING
THESE KINDS OF STORIES, STILL
REFUSE TO RESPECT
NATIONAL ANTHEM TODAY?
OR WHEN MIDFIELDER ALLIE LONG
DRAGS THE AMERICAN FLAG ON THE
GROUND WHILE REPRESENTING THE
U.S. ON THE WORLD STAGE?
AND WHILE MUGGING FOR THE
CAMERAS, THEN DROPS THE FLAG
LIKE IT'S A PIECE OF TRASH.
THANKFULLY, ANOTHER MIDFIELDER
KELLY O'HARA PICKED IT UP.
AND OF COURSE, DISCOVERED EARLY
ON THAT PERMANENT MVP STATUS
WHEN YOU KICK A DONALD TRUMP.
LIKE WHEN SHE USED FOUL LANGUAGE
MIXING ANY TRADITIONAL
WHITE HOUSE VISIT TO THE
CHAMPIONS.
THIS IS BEFORE THEY EVEN WON THE
WORLD CUP.
THE EASIEST TASK TO SOCIAL MEDIA
START TODAY IS ONE WHERE YOU
TAKE CHEAP SWIPES AND AMERICA
SYMBOLS AND TRADITIONS.
AND HE MUST UNDERSTAND THAT THE
LEFT TRULY BELIEVES AMERICA
ITSELF IS ILLEGITIMATE TO ITS
CORE.
ONE OF MY TALKING ABOUT?
WELL, ITS FOUNDING WAS
FRAUDULENT.
THEY BELIEVE ITS FOUNDING
DOCUMENTS, MEANINGLESS.
ALL BECAUSE OF SLAVERY.
AND THE PEOPLE WHO ARE INVOLVED
IN IT.
OUR PROGRESS ON RACIAL ISSUES IS
CONVENIENTLY IGNORED BY CYNICAL
ACTORS WHO ARE FRANKLY USING
THESE PAST ORDERS FOR A POWER
GRAB AND, THEY HOPE, A TOTAL
REORGANIZATION OF OUR SOCIETY
HERE AND A MASSIVE WEALTH
CONFISCATION.
THE PHRASE WHITE PRIVILEGE, IT
IS NOW THE PREFERRED WEAPON OF
CHOICE, AND IS USED BY SOCIALIST
KNOW-NOTHINGS TO TAR THEIR
POLITICAL OPPONENTS AND AVOID
REAL DEBATE.
ONLY GUESS WHAT?
NOW EVEN OLD WHITE DEMOCRATS ARE
IN THE PRIVILEGE CROSS HAIRS.
>> JOE BIDEN FUMBLES ALL THE
TIME.
JOE BIDEN SUFFERS FROM OLD WHITE
MALE ENTITLEMENT WHERE HE JUST
CAN'T SIMPLY SAY I WAS WRONG.
>> Laura: LIBERAL WOMEN AREN'T
IMMUNE EITHER.
THIS WEEK, SPEAKER PELOSI
LEARNED THAT THE RACE TABLES CAN
QUICKLY BE TURNED ON HER, TOO.
SHE IS NOW UNDER FIRE BY THE
FOUR HORSE WOMEN OF THE
APOCALYPSE.
FRESHMAN CONGRESSWOMAN, WHO
CLAIM PELOSI'S "SINGLING OUT THE
NEWLY ELECTED OF COLOR."
WHEN ASKED TODAY ABOUT THE
CHARGE, THIS IS HOW
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ
RESPONDED.
>> KNOWING THE MEDIA ENVIRONMENT
THAT WE ARE OPERATING IN,
KNOWING THE AMOUNT OF DEATH
THREATS WE GET, KNOWING THE
AMOUNT OF CONCENTRATION AND
ATTENTION, I THINK IT'S JUST
WORTH ASKING WHY?
>> DO YOU THINK IT IS RACIAL
ANIMUS?
>> NOW, NO.
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
>> Laura: THAT IS A NEAT
TRICK, ISN'T IT?
AOC BLAST ANYONE ANYTIME OF THE
DAY OR NIGHT ON SOCIAL MEDIA BUT
WHEN THE LEADER OF HER OWN
PARTY CALLED HER OUT, SHE CRIES
FOUL.
NO, NO, NANCY IS NOT A RACIST.
WELL, BUT, PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
ROUTINELY SUBJECTED TO THIS KIND
OF ATTACK.
HIS PLAN TO PUT CITIZENSHIP, THE
QUESTION ON THE FENCES WAS
DERIDED AS RACIST BY DEMOCRATS.
AND TODAY, HE SHOT BACK.
>> NOW THEY ARE TRYING TO ERASE
THE VERY EXISTENCE OF A VERY
IMPORTANT WORD AND A VERY
IMPORTANT THING, CITIZENSHIP.
WE MUST HAVE A RELIABLE COUNT OF
HOW MANY CITIZENS, NONCITIZENS
AND ILLEGAL ALIENS ARE IN OUR
COUNTRY.
>> Laura: BINGO.
HOW IS THIS CONTROVERSIAL?
ASKING ABOUT CITIZENSHIP?
IT'S LIKE A QUESTION THAT HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH RACE AT ALL.
IT'S ABOUT WHO IS AMERICAN AND
WHO IS NOT.
BY THE WAY, AFRICAN-AMERICANS
HAVE BEEN THE MOST DIRECTLY
IMPACTED BY THE MAST DOMINIC
MASS FLOW OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
IN THE UNITED STATES
NO WONDER POLLS NOW SHOW A
MAJORITY OF BLACK AND HISPANIC
VOTERS SUPPORT ADDING THE
QUESTION TO THE SENSES.
ERASING OUR HISTORY, OUR SENSE
OF WHO WE ARE IS MAKING IT
EASIER TO TURN AMERICA INTO JUST
KIND OF ANOTHER MEMBER OF A
GLOBALIST SUPERSTATE.
EUROPEANS SACRIFICED THEIR
IDENTITY YEARS AGO ON THE ALTAR
OF GLOBALISM WHEN THEY FORMED
THE EUROPEAN UNION.
LOOK AT WHAT IT GOT THEM.
[ALL SINGING]
>> Laura: WE MAY HAVE MASS
MORONS OF ANTIFA TO DEAL WITH
BUT WE DON'T HAVE YELLOW VEST
SHUTTING DOWN ENTIRE CITIES OR A
BREXIT STYLE MESS TO DEAL WITH.
OR A RECESSION ON THE HORIZON
LIKE WE SEE WITH GERMANY.
THERE IS A PRICE FOR
SURRENDERING YOUR SOVEREIGNTY